the scene opens with an unidentified man
strapped to a bed in a mysterious
looking room there are several pieces of
medical equipment attached to his body
indicating that he is either sick or
injured soon he regains Consciousness
and a voice on the microphone inquires
if he remembers his name the
unidentified man replies that he is Raf
Hanks a famous political campaign
manager however when the voice asks him
if he knows the president he remains
silent the movie then flashes back to
five years ago where Raph is at the peak
of his career he is currently
campaigning for James Stevens an
overwhelming favorite candidate for the
U.S presidential election when RAF peeks
through his office he notices several
thousand people chanting for James even
all the TV channels are sure that it is
going to be a one-sided Victory this
makes Raph very proud as James was once
a nobody in fact he was despised by all
his friends and family members for
something he did in the past his life
was on a downward spiral until RAF found
him and changed his fortune in the next
scene we see RAF talking to his
assistant Maura McGowan he is so full of
himself that he has written a book
called vunderkind which means being
successful at a young age RAF also
boasts that he wants a movie dedicated
to him and that Justin Timberlake should
play his character and if we can't get
JT then I don't know maybe uh maybe
chalamet he continues bragging about his
accolades but right then they are
informed that the election results are
out as wrath and Mora enter James's room
they are taken aback to see everyone
with a gloomy face in a shocking turn of
events it is revealed that James
overwhelmingly lost the election even in
his home state of New Jersey enraged he
chastised his wrath for being a total
failure before firing him on the spot
this hurts the latter's ego so badly
that he plunges into a deep abyss of
anxiety okay fine we'll get Michael
Sarah to play me in the movie cut to
several years later Raph is still not
recovered from the traumatic experience
he has since quit his political career
and spends most of his time at the bar
are drinking gone are the days where he
used to think of making his own movie
with Justin Timberlake as the lead actor
the country is also going through a
tough period because of high
unemployment rate high crime rate and
several other negative reasons one day
as RAF is drinking at his usual spot a
news report on TV reveals that an 11
year old YouTuber named Oliver Foley has
announced his candidacy for the upcoming
presidential election he has posted a
video on his channel in which he
promises to bring peace and happiness
amongst his countrymen if he comes into
power but being a kid Oliver also
promises to provide everyone with free
video games as according to him they
improve hand-eye coordination I'm voting
for Ollie RAF who is watching this in a
drunken state becomes impressed with a
smile on his face he then hatches a plan
Raph believes that in these tough times
most people will vote for the kid as he
is genuine honest and sweet he also
takes it as the perfect opportunity to
reinvigorate his career so without
giving it a second thought Raph decides
to get back to politics chalamet here I
come the next day he visits the Foley
residents and has dinner with the family
Oliver's parents are happy that their
son has gone viral on the internet but
they believe that he was just joking at
the tender age of 11 it is simply not
possible to get into politics let alone
govern a country however wrath who is
desperate to get his career back on
track thinks otherwise he explains that
Oliver has something which the other
politicians don't have a genuine
connection with the public using this he
can easily amass a lot of followers and
win the election RAF states that even if
Oliver doesn't become the president he
will still be a celebrity which will
earn him millions in endorsements
hearing all this the parents eventually
allow Raph to lead their son in the
presidential campaign later that night
Oliver records another video where he
talks about all the reforms he is going
to make once he becomes the president
for instance there will be three
holidays a week the winter holidays will
be extended by a month all the Star Wars
movies will be banned Ollie every single
person in the country will be given a
video video game of their choice and so
on in no time the video goes viral and
so Oliver's campaign officially Begins
the very next day we see him making
promises in front of a large audience he
also performs an impressive dance
routine which he posts on his YouTube
channel to get more recognition all this
is being supervised and coordinated by
none other than wrath he is finally
making up for the debacle he suffered
some years ago as the days pass Raph
becomes so popular and loved that even
his ex-assistant Mora comes back to him
in the next scene we are shown that the
11 year old boys managed to amass a
serious fan following despite his young
age many people believe that he is the
right person to lead the country because
of his pure heart and because let's face
it we'd all do anything for a three-day
weekend they are ready to take the risk
claiming that nothing can be worse than
the state they are in in this way RAF
continues leading the campaign to
success but as Oliver gets popular he
also becomes arrogant The Cheeky brat
regularly berates his parents and other
staff without any remorse in particular
he doesn't like going going to the
doctor as he is scared of needles RAF
who is always with the boy notices all
this but doesn't say a word a few more
days pass and the presidential debate is
just around the corner Raph has hired
some of his best politicians teachers
and other Scholars to educate the boy
but to no avail no matter how talented
and woke Oliver is he is still an 11
year old he can't grasp the basics of
politics let alone face the cameras or
go up against some of the most
experienced politicians in the country
nonetheless Raph decides to proceed with
the debate as they have come too far to
fail just say the thing about the video
games again kid unfortunately the
decision turns out to be a disastrous
one as Oliver the kid humiliates not
only himself but his entire team on live
television when the going gets tough he
even calls his mommy to take him home
everyone sympathizes with Oliver as he
is just an 11 year old but as for wrath
he is again accused of failing the
campaign so the very next day he again
reverts to alcoholism he is now done
with politics as no matter how hard he
try eyes he buries himself in an even
deeper grave one day Maura visits wrath
at his usual drinking spot and reveals
that she met the foleys earlier turns
out they're going through a tough period
not because Oliver lost the presidential
debate but because of their beloved dog
Homer dying of cancer hearing this
another idea strikes raph's drunken mind
since people sympathize with dogs he
wants Oliver to make another video in
which he will share his happy memories
with Homer the plan is to gain the
attention of the people and ultimately
win them over Mora thinks that it is a
bad idea as it could easily go south
baraf simply says it's time to make or
break we gotta use this dog cancer this
time the plan finally works as soon as
the emotional video hits the internet it
becomes a viral sensation people start
pouring Oliver with their deepest
sympathies and once again turn to his
side the movie then cuts to a few days
later where it is revealed that Oliver
has won the election by a landslide he
is now officially the president of the
United States of America a massive rally
takes place to celebrate his victory
where millions of people line up on the
streets it is evident that raph's idea
has won the hearts of the Americans
dog's still dead though later after the
celebrations are over Oliver and his
team finally arrive at the White House
he is ecstatic to start his tenure as
the president but at the same time his
arrogance has reached Sky Heights Oliver
orders his cabinet members to distribute
video games to all the citizens of the
country and when they hesitate he
threatens to fire them he even
disregards his mom and Raph when they
try to explain that the decision is a
bad one so with no options left the
cabinet members agree and leave the room
as the days pass Oliver's outrageous
demands continue to increase we see that
he has installed a popcorn machine
inside his office and brought a bunch of
penguins from Antarctica moreover he has
deployed a swing in place of the
presidential chair so far I see no
issues here the following day he ordered
several dogs to be brought to his office
as he wants to adopt one however when he
finds out that all of them are female he
angrily asks them to be taken out Oliver
claims that his beloved Homer was a male
so he wants a dog resembling him RAF and
the other members are stunned to see his
arrogance dude this guy's sexist towards
animals but nonetheless they comply
without uttering a word the same day the
vice president approaches Oliver and
requests that he undergo a medical
examination however the Arrogant brat
starts shouting saying that he is well
and fine when the VP asserts that it is
a rule made compulsory by the Congress
Oliver orders the Congress to be
dissolved immediately he then starts
throwing his ball around the room
hurting some people in the process
worried that something terrible is about
to happen Ralph later meets the military
Chief and asks him to educate the boy he
wants to make sure that no one gets
affected by Oliver's abrupt and childish
Antics unfortunately the military Chief
takes this as an offense and he calls
RAF a traitor the latter immediately
apologizes but the damage has already
been done that evening RAF again starts
worrying about his career despite
everything that he has achieved he
believes that he has made the wrong
choice by helping Oliver become the
president however his best friend and
only confidante Mora argues that the 11
year old is doing a good job she says
that Raph is simply overthinking things
and that he should take some rest
however our protagonist is not going to
let the Injustice slide so easily so the
following day he approaches Oliver while
he is playing golf in his office he
wants to politely make the boy
understand that whatever he is doing is
wrong RAF then grabs a golf stick and
starts explaining the responsibilities
of a president to the country they
should be brave and lead the people in
difficult times unfortunately Oliver
takes it the wrong way and becomes angry
he starts throwing things around and
demands an apology but this time Raph is
having none of it he bluntly refuses to
apologize and even calls the boy stupid
hearing this Oliver orders his security
to take action oh you really stepped in
it now big boy and as the camera pans
out we see blood splattered on the walls
following this we are taken back to the
Mysterious Room that we saw at the start
of the movie Raph is tied to a bed and
it is revealed that he survived the
gunshot wounds however due to the
excessive loss of blood he has to be
operated on immediately in the last
scene the doctor is signed by Oliver
finally arrives he is another 11 year
old boy who probably has no experience
in surgery to make matters worse he
wants to finish the procedure ASAP so
that he can go back to playing video
games the movie ends as poor RAF screams
in horror as his life is slowly taken
away from him